Hello friends and some TV family. This
is I'd like to know our Bible question
and answer program here at SumTV. Thank
you for joining us uh today. We pray
that what we have to talk about will be
a blessing to you, information and
inspiration as we answer your questions
from the word of God. I'm CA Murray. To
my right, Pastor Steven Boore, president
of this ministry. To my left, Pastor
David Salazar, general manager of our
Latino network. And thank you again for
joining us. Should you want to get your
question answered, we ask you to send it
into tvsumsv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org.
Now, we ask you to allow us the
privilege of combining some questions.
And sometimes we get duplicate
questions. So you may not hear your
question as exactly as you ask it. But
when other people have the same bird and
ask the same question, we will combine
the question uh to facilitate a quicker
answer, helping us to get to your
question that much quicker. So we thank
you and we encourage you keep on sending
in your questions. We will get to them
just as soon as we possibly can. Pastor
Boore, if you would ask the Lord's
blessing on our sitting today, we shall
launch out into question number one.
>> Let's pray.
Father in heaven, as long as we live in
this world, we'll have multiple
questions.
>> But the wonderful thing is that in the
future, we'll be able to fit sit at the
feet of Jesus and ask as many questions
as we want and receive absolutely
certain and correct answers.
>> Amen.
>> How we long for that day. But meanwhile,
we're here. And so we ask the presence
of your Holy Spirit as we seek to answer
the questions that have been sent in to
our ministry. Give us divine wisdom to
answer correctly
>> and bless those who will watch the
program. We pray this in the precious
and holy name of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our question number one,
the first question comes from I'm not
sure how to pron
I
don't want to butcher this name up so
I'm not going to take it's un or un uh
we don't have a a a place but thank you
for your question and we appreciate you
sending it in. Here's the question. Adam
and Eve were perfectly created by God.
Why would God ask them to tend and keep
the garden? How does one tend and keep
something that is perfect? That's an
interesting question, interesting angle
on uh this particular text, Genesis
2:15.
Um, whoever gets there first can read
it, pastor. Okay.
>> And it says, "Then the Lord God took the
man and put him in the garden of Eden to
tend and keep it."
>> All righty.
>> Um, Ellen White does gives us some help
here on this on this understanding. Um
years ago I was uh doing a wedding and
there was a young man who was going to
carry the Bible down the aisle and he
had a perfectly white suit on and uh the
church is under repair and uh somehow a
little mouse got into the pastor's
office and the the the bride jumped up
on on the pastor's desk and everybody
scattered and we don't know where that
little boy ran but when he came back
that white suit was black. it was filthy
[laughter]
and uh we couldn't we couldn't get him
clean. We had to take off the jacket and
just go with his shirt and you know kind
of thing. And [snorts] so I in looking
at that I asked my question is it harder
to get something clean or to keep
something clean you know uh he started
out clean but he wasn't able to keep it
clean.
>> Well because it isn't perfect doesn't
mean that it doesn't have to be tended
or looked after. Vines grow, things are
planted, things move. uh it it is a
testament to the power of God to have
living things grow that you have to
dress and keep. So because it is
perfect, which means that it was
perfectly suited for the purpose that it
was created, doesn't mean that it didn't
have to be kept perfect, kept clean,
kept in pristine condition. Uh so that's
my little pee in a pot. You know also
it's important to notice that God is
actually in this verse giving the
declaration that he had a purpose for
men to do in the sense of he had a task
to do some sort of occupation to keep
himself occupied. Um it's not work as in
the in the sense that we understand it
today. It was not to sweat and and and
and have to labor hard. It was a way to
keep that person Adam and Eve occupied,
tending, taking care of. Every human or
every creature of God has a purpose of
serving someone else, providing some
service to others. And uh you know from
the grass to the plants to the fruits,
the trees to the animals. And so Adam as
given the role of taking care of the
earth as being the one to you know uh
reign over the earth. It was his duty
his role to keep it address like you
said maintain it and it would again it
was a blessing for man to be occupied.
If he was to be idol I mean idol is not
a good thing being idol. So God had to
make sure that he keep himself occupied
and that was a way for God to have him
uh grow and learn as he was tending to
the garden.
>> You know, it's interesting that um the
Garden of Eden did not see the effects
of sin.
>> Mhm.
>> After Adam and Eve were cast out, it
remained absolutely perfect.
>> And yet God tells us in Genesis 2:15
that he placed Adam and Eve in the
garden,
>> right? primarily Adam in the case of
chapter 2 and verse 15 to tend and keep
it.
>> So even in a perfect garden,
they had to tend and keep it. Um somehow
they probably had to plant the seeds
and uh and you know they probably had to
to um um you know the the tree branches
grew
uh
>> Mhm.
>> a lot.
>> Mhm. and the plants grew a lot and maybe
they had to prune everything. Pruning
does not mean that it wasn't that it
wasn't perfect. Uh Ellen White had made
a very interesting comment in story of
redemption page 21. She says although
everything God had made was in the
perfection of beauty
>> and there seemed nothing wanting upon
the earth which God had created to make
Adam and Eve happy. Yet he manifested
his great love to them by planting a
garden especially for them. A portion of
their time was to be occupied in the
happy employment of dressing the garden
>> and a portion in receiving the visits of
angels
>> listening to their instruction in a
happy meditation.
Their labor was not weariesome but
pleasant
>> and invigorating.
>> This beautiful garden was to be their
home. So it required exercise.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it says that uh it wasn't
weariesome but it was pleasant and
invigorating.
>> Yes.
>> But after sin when they were cast out
>> Yeah.
>> to the earth. We're told in Genesis
chapter 3 that the earth created uh from
the earth came thorns and thistles.
>> Yeah.
>> And Ellen White said that it uh became
more difficult to till the soil.
>> The work became on the sweat of thy
brow. Yes.
>> According to the Bible. So,
[clears throat] but before uh you know
they probably had to prune trees and
they had to you know beautify the garden
if you please. But how can you beautify
something that is perfect? Well, you
need to keep it perfect. Amen. To use
your illustration,
>> right?
>> Uh so, uh you know, the bottom line is
that in the garden, their work was
pleasurable once they were cast out of
the garden. It was in the sweat of their
brow.
>> Well said. I think we tend to define
work uh from Genesis 3:19 that you
referred to, in the sweat of your face
shall you eat bread. That's that's what
labor is to us. You know, the ground is
going to fight you now. It's not going
to work with you. It's not going to
cooperate with you. You have to sweat to
get something out of the ground. But but
and we are told that throughout the
ceases ages of eternity, we'll have
stuff to do. You know,
>> idleness is not a blessing. It's not a
blessing to sit around and do nothing.
You know, you need something to do
that's pleasant. And if you love what
you're doing,
>> I've never considered ministry work. And
I really have not. It's it's something I
believe I was called to do and that I I
like doing. That's why at 70 plus years
I'm still doing it. Amen.
>> Uh because it's still a blessing to me.
So it's not work per se. There are times
when it's it's tough, but it's not it's
not work. Well, the the labor that they
were given was not work. Was not
drudgery, as you well said, was not
hard. It was a pleasant thing to do to
keep that which was perfect in perfect
condition.
>> Right. It's it's kind of like um
[clears throat] it's kind of like when
we receive Christ as our savior,
he gives us the white robe of his
righteousness.
>> Yeah.
>> But Revelation 16:15 says that we need
to keep our garments
>> clean. [laughter]
So, so they were to keep the garden.
>> That's right.
>> Perfect. If you please.
>> Yeah. There's another quote that kind of
sums our eyes and and brings something
that is also important to keep in mind.
This is found in our high calling page
223. It says, "God placed men in the
garden of the Eden. He surrounded him
with everything that could contribute to
his happiness and place him upon the
responsibility to of labor. The creator
knew that Adam could not be happy
without employment. That means doing
keeping himself occupied. The beauty of
the garden delighted him. But this was
not enough. He must have labored to
calling to exercise the wonderful organs
of the body. So for him to use his arms,
his fingers, his lungs, I mean that
everything that the Lord provided, it
was a way that that employment, that
labor, that pending to the garden as he
could delight and he could uh be happy.
He couldn't be happy without it, without
being occupied. And like you said,
pastor, you know, in heaven, we're not
going to be idle. We're not going to be
playing an AR harp all, you know, all
day as some people have imagined. You
know, we're going to have things to do.
It's not going to be work like we have
it today, but we're gonna be active. And
God has given us today the calling to do
that, to put in practice even today our
our body and exercise. And so, uh, I can
see this is why God gave him that role
and that calling.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, well said both of you
gentlemen. Our high calling is a great
devotional, by the way. Um, I have it on
my phone. I've got the hard copy, too.
Every now and again, I go back to it for
for inspiration. Thank you so much,
Pastor Boore. This is coming from Greg.
We don't know where it is coming from.
Would you read this particular question
for?
>> Well, uh before I read the question, I
want to say that I kind of get the
impression
uh that this question is being asked by
a person who is not an Adventist.
um a person who believes that uh the
little horn of Daniel chapter 8 is
>> Antiochas Epiphanies
>> who was uh uh Greek ruler towards the
end of the Grecian kingdom
>> right
>> um actually uh around the year 165 BC um
if Daniel 8 is about the reign of Greece
and the Jews and the daily being given
over to it that is to the little horn
who came out of one of the four uh Greek
kingdoms after Alexander the Great died.
How is it that you teach that this
prophecy has nothing to do with Greece?
Because we say that the little horn
represents the papacy, right? So, how is
it that we say that this prophecy about
the little horn doesn't apply to
Antaspies in the Grecian kingdom and we
apply it to the little horn in the Roman
kingdom,
>> right? Uh I just need to clarify the
question a little bit. Uh so it says uh
how is it that you teach that this
prophecy has nothing to do with Greece
nor the sanctuary on earth? Why do you
believe that the 23 2300 evenings and
mornings are years and not days?
Why do you believe the prophecy started
long before Greece conquered Meo Persia?
And why do you teach that the sanctuary
in Daniel 8:14 refers to the sanctuary
in heaven when Jesus attended the
celebration commemorating the
deliverance of the Jews and the
restoration of the sanctuary as seen in
John 10:20. Uh this is a multi- uh
faceted question.
>> Yeah. And uh it has to be answered
briefly because we can't take uh 10
programs [laughter] to go through
everything. Uh basically the Adventist
church believes that Daniel 8 is
repeating some details that are not
found in Daniel chapter 7.
>> Right?
>> And there are multiple characteristics
that indicate that the little horn of
Daniel 8 is the same little horn of
Daniel chapter
>> 7. M
>> uh the problem is with this little horn
coming out of one of the four horns into
which Alexander's kingdom was divided.
Um uh if the horn came out of one of the
four horns of the Grecian kingdom, then
how do we say that it's a little horn
that comes out of the Roman kingdom? Uh
the bottom line is that I believe
personally that we have misidentified
uh the four horns that came out after
Alexander's death. Uh we have usually
said that they are the four generals of
uh of Alexander the Great that
distributed what had been of his kingdom
into two parts.
>> Right. Um I disagree with one of those
kingdoms that has traditionally been uh
>> sign identified as one of the kingdoms
>> and that is the kingdom of Pergamum.
And on this program I can't uh really
express fully the meaning of the kingdom
of Pergamum.
Pagan Rome had its origin in Asia Minor
where Pergamum is. So the fourth of
those horns is really Pergamum for from
where uh pagan Rome grew and papal Rome
later grew
>> right
>> uh from pagan Rome.
>> Um so the little horn actually
represents pagan Rome and it represents
papal Rome that come forth that grow
forth from Pergamum. Now, if you want a
full explanation of this, uh, you have
to go to my study notes on Daniel,
almost a thousand pages that I wrote for
for one of our anchor schools of
theology.
>> And there's a whole exposition of this
in uh what I had to say about Daniel
chapter 8. Now, why do we say that the
sanctuary that has to be cleansed uh is
actually the sanctuary in heaven? Well,
because uh Jerusalem was destroyed in
the year 70 along with the temple.
>> Correct?
>> So, at the end of the 2300 days, the
temple didn't exist.
So, so it has to be the temple in
heaven. Furthermore, the book of Hebrews
tells us that the sanctuary that is in
play now is the heavenly sanctuary
course during the Christian
dispensation. Uh so there are many
questions here uh that that bear uh more
you really need more time to answer
them. Now why did Jesus attend the feast
of dedication?
Uh in John chap 10 22 it says that Jesus
went to the feast of dedication. Now the
feast of dedication is a post-biblical
celebration.
uh they actually celebr the Jews
celebrated the rededication of the
temple uh after Antiochas Epiphanies had
desecrated it by sacrificing a a pig pig
>> on the altar. And so the Jews
established a celebration post-biblical
not part of the Mosaic legislation to
commemorate the liberation of the Jews
and the rededication of the temple after
it had been desecrated. Now, the fact
that Jesus attended the feast of
dedication in his day doesn't
necessarily mean that he believed that
the little horn of Daniel chapter 8 was
the little horn as the Jews, Josephus,
understood it.
>> It simply means that there was a feast
in Jerusalem and Jesus attended that
feast.
>> So, this is all I'm going to say about
this question. M
>> it's a it's a multiaceted question that
we really can't answer fully on this
program but I would refer uh the asker
of the question uh to go to my study
notes uh notes on Daniel uh it's
available if you download our app our
downloading of our app is free and there
you'll have a full answer to all of the
questions that are made here.
>> Amen.
>> I think it's very very very very good.
It's it's hard to be concise when when
the the subject matter is so profound.
Um [snorts] I would add also that all of
the the the cell you said kings and uh
kings and east all of them took the name
Antiochus. Um Epiphanies named himself
that you know there was no particular
reason for him to stand out. All of them
were Antiochus. Antiochus the first the
second and third epistles they all took
that took that name. But uh they don't
particularly distinguish themselves in
in in history, let alone prophecy. Um so
if you if you take the 2,300 days as
literal days, they really take you
nowhere. They just they just stop. It
takes you nowhere. It doesn't make sense
prophetically uh to use it as literal
days. You've got to use Numbers 4,
Ezekiel 4, Numbers 14, Ezekiel 4, uh the
day your principal,
>> right? And uh also in those study notes
on Daniel, I have a long chapter on the
year-day principle.
>> The fact that in prophecy a day is equal
to a year. And so uh the 23 that 70
weeks are cut off from the 2300 days.
>> So if the 70 weeks are not literal
weeks, but they're weeks of years, then
the rest of the prophecy must also be uh
we must also apply uh the year-day
principle.
>> Yes. And you know just uh a little quick
point the the vision itself the vision
of Daniel chapter 8 it's for the time of
the end it aims to time of the end I
mean the Bible says it's the time of the
end it's not possible to have just you
know fit in that time which was just uh
a few centuries after it doesn't really
connect with that and there's other
reasons but I think it's important for
this person to like you said uh listen
to their explanation the full
explanation
And after that compare it with the
scriptures
>> and also the fact that Daniel 8 tells us
that this little horn that comes up is a
super powerful horn.
>> Mhm.
>> Well, Antiochus Epiphanies was one of
the weaker
>> of the of the Antiochuses. And so it
there are all kinds of evidences that
that the prophecy does not fit Antiochus
Epiphanies. Even though Josephus uh
believed that the little horn was
Antiochus, uh we don't go by Josephus.
We there's been a lot more study given
to this 2,000 years.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> To simply accept uh uh what Josephus had
to say.
>> Yeah. I think your your your point,
Pastor David, that you've got to work
out your numbering system so that it
brings you to the time of the end.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh 2300 days, which is a little over
little under 10 years, takes you
nowhere. It does nothing. It's just it
just stops. Yeah.
>> Uh you've got to use a mechanism to
bring you all the way down to the end of
time. And only thing that does that is
the year-day principle, which is stated
in the Bible, at least on two occasions.
Uh, and we know that it applies to to
pro prophecy. So, well done, gentlemen.
Well done.
>> Well done. I hope uh
>> was this Greg? Yes.
>> That uh we gave you some food for
thought and I hope that you avail
yourselves of the study notes. They are
exhaustive
uh without being exhausting, but they
are exhaustive and [laughter] they will
give you they will give you the answers
that that you seek. If you really want
truth, then the Bible says pursue it. Uh
and here is an avenue for you to get
truth uh by looking at and reading and
working your way through these study
notes. Can these be downloaded, pastor?
>> Yeah.
>> Can this particular set of study notes
have
>> they can be downloaded? They can be
copied. They can be shared. Yeah.
>> There's only one regulation and that is
don't sell them.
>> Yeah.
>> Because that way you're profiting from
the work of someone else.
>> Yes.
>> So So the only prohibition is don't sell
them. Mhm.
>> You can share them, you can print them
and uh and use them for personal use.
>> Uh but uh don't sell them.
>> Yes, that's what's so wonderful about
the study. We you can get them in any
form. I like to download things, but I
also like having paper in front of me
because I cannot read a book. I don't
borrow books from people without a pen
in my hand. I've got to make notes. I've
got to highlight. So if I borrow your
book and give it back to you, you won't
recognize it because it will be beat up
pretty bad. So when I if I got those
study notes, um, in fact, I do have them
in my office, they have pen marks on
them because I tend to write a lot.
>> And we have lots of people that even
though they can get them for free
online,
>> they have to have a hard copy.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Because they like to circle words, they
like to put notes in the margins, they
like to add concepts and so on. So, so
really uh you know you can acquire uh a
nice copy for actually two volumes. Uh
you can get them in hard copy form from
Secrets Unsealed uh in a real nice
format.
>> Yeah. And they they look good uh well
done, well produced uh graphically uh
inviting. The print is nice and large
which as I get a little bit older I
appreciate. We did it for you [laughter]
>> and I appreciate it.
We notice even Pastor Salazar, a young
man, several years younger than I has
has moved into glasses on you.
[laughter]
>> Yielded yielded to the vicissitudes of
old age of old of growing older and you
look good, pastor, with the with the
glasses. We we appreciate that. Um, our
time is almost gone. I don't think we
have quite enough to get into another
question. We want to encourage you to to
continue to write. As we said, we take
the no bless sometimes to combine
questions, but um continue to write. We
will answer them as best we can, as
quickly as we can. And um you want to
write to TV atsumtv.org.
Again, our time has fast lit into
eternity. Allow us in closing to wish
you both grace and peace through our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. We'll see
you again soon. Bye-bye and God bless.
Heat. Heat.